signore scenari minuti a portare bonacci
1930 prova vicino noi mettiamo spegnersi
disposizione c'erano c'era cinture
sicurezza
c'è una compagna simona tris entrano
fascino vi sono folletto vendevano senza
enfasi non sia il passo in queste ora ci
sono se uscite di sicurezza anteriori
del centro e due posteriori in caso di
emergenza luce del pavimento
liquideranno persone uscita di sicurezza
signora gentilmente la zona deve essere
messa in campania na vengono guardi che
non ci sta certo che c'è sachs signora
signora scudi desidera qualcosa da bere
tè o caffè succo davvero non so no non
ce l'abbiamo dolce salato ma la montagna
è che se i talami sono 45 euro
oddio ma che succede ma leggerissima
turbolenza faceva lasciata marinara ci
auguriamo di avere presto a bordo